practicamos un poco entendiendo las
variables y los números negativos que
puedan representar o los números
positivos
nos dicen que ordenemos las siguientes
expresiones por sus valores del más
pequeño al más grande y nos dan estas
tres expresiones con menos n n y n menos
q y luego trazaron n
en la recta numérica y solo para
orientarnos veamos tres marcas a la
izquierda del cero es menos 3 por lo que
en cada marca vamos a abajo una unidad
este debe de ser menos 1 esté menos 2 y
este menos 3 y luego mientras vamos a la
derecha cada marca debe de incrementar 1
es 0 1 2 y luego 3 y esto sólo nos ayuda
a orientarnos más ahora sólo pensemos en
cada una de estas expresiones esta
primera es q menos n y la q está a la
derecha de la n en la recta numérica
sabemos que como es mayor que él
si q es mayor que n y está restando n de
q de hecho no importa si ambas son
negativas o ambas son positivas o una es
positiva y la otra negativa sólo el
hecho de saber que es mayor a n eso
significa que con menos n será positivo
y si de hecho quieres ver esta
circunstancia en particular q es
positiva en es negativa si resta su
negativo estás esencialmente sumando un
positivo así que este valor de aquí no
solo será positivo será un valor
positivo mayor aquí
y si tuviéramos que comparar ese valor
con q sabríamos que es mayor aquí pero
no nos piden que hagamos eso ahora
tenemos a la n n es un valor negativo es
un número negativo entre -1 y -2 parece
que es casi parece que es
aproximadamente menos 1.8 no estamos
totalmente seguros pero a simple vista
este valor es negativo y parece que es
aproximadamente menos 1.8 ahora cuanto
es n menos q n
bueno será el negativo de menos n n
menos q tenemos este número más pequeño
y le estamos restando el número mayor
así que el resultado de esto será
negativo por lo que el mayor de estos
valores
definitivamente será q menos 7 el cual
será positivo y luego tenemos que
descubrir cuál será más negativo
este valor en este valor de n
pensamos un poco en eso podríamos solo
intentar aproximar el valor de q y si lo
vemos parece que es aproximadamente
parece que es casi 0.8
y este parece que es aproximadamente lo
que ya dijimos menos 1.8 si hacemos esas
suposiciones aquí esto será
aproximadamente aproximadamente menos
1.8 menos 0.8 lo que es igual a menos
2.6 cuando lo ves de esta manera
claramente ves que esto será más
negativo que este valor de aquí así que
es
el menor
el más pequeño y este es el más
más grande
y digamos que este es el menor y este es
el mayor y si quisiéramos ordenarlos
tendríamos n
q
y luego si estás haciendo esto en el
ejercicio de la página de khan academy
puedes de hecho dar clic en estos y
moverlos pero si no podemos sería
- q
que es el más negativo y luego tienes
que aún es negativo pero no más negativo
que este valor de aquí este de aquí es
aproximadamente menos 1.8 esto es
aproximadamente menos 2.6 y luego
- n
lo que será aproximadamente
aproximadamente 2.6 positivos así que
esto es
este es el mayor y entonces contestemos
la siguiente pregunta contestemos la
siguiente pregunta
ven a las siguientes expresiones por sus
valores del menor al mayor y nuevamente
es casi el mismo ejercicio nada más que
aquí cada marca parece representar media
unidad porque se requieren dos para
llegar a uno esto es la mitad esto de
aquí es menos un medio y queremos
comparar a menos b con a y con a menos
0.5 todas estas son a menos un valor
podemos incluso pensar en esto como a
menos a menos cero cierto y eso es lo
mismo que a veamos en todas estas
opciones tenemos una y le estamos
restando un valor aquí no estamos
restando bueno le estamos restando 0 le
estamos restando nada aquí restamos b y
aquí restamos 0.5 en general
mientras más rest es entre más rest es
más pequeños será el resultado veamos en
cuál de estos casos le estoy restando
más aquí estoy restando un número
positivo
aquí estoy restando 0 aquí estoy
restando b que es un número negativo
aquí estoy restando un número negativo b
es negativo
este claramente es positivo
así que si restas un número positivo de
a obtendrás un número más pequeño que si
resta su número negativo si resta su
número negativo
vas a sumarle a obtendrás un valor mayor
así que el más pequeño es cuando restas
el número mayor o el valor más grande en
a menos 0.5 estamos restando un número
positivo ahí estamos restando 0.5
seguido por a donde no estamos restando
nada y luego tienes a menos b este de
aquí será el mayor y a qué se debe esto
sabemos que b es un número negativo
observa que es menor a 0
si ve es un número negativo restas un
número negativo obtendrás un valor que
es mayor a déjame aclarar esto este
valor de aquí será menor que a este
valor de aquí claramente es igual
y este valor de aquí será de hecho mayor
que a y ahora lo ordenamos del menor al
mayor y nuevamente si lo estuvieras
haciendo en un ejercicio de la página de
khan academy tendríamos una pequeña
herramienta donde podríamos dar clic en
estos cuadros y moverlos
pero este es el menor seguido por este
seguido por este
y otra manera en la cual lo podrías
hacer tal cual como lo hicimos en el
último ejemplo podría solo estimar
aproximadamente el valor de estos
valores parece que es no es exactamente
pero parece que es alrededor de menos
0.2 aproximadamente menos 0.2
recuerda esto es media mitad negativa
esto es menos 0.5
parece que es aproximadamente no sé
menos 0.7
menos 0.7 y de hecho podrías hacerlo con
los valores exactos si quisieras pero
obtendrías el mismo resultado